enfin parce que techniquement je serai
toujours dans le même secteur enfin j'ai
pas si je suis très clair c'est
parfaitement clair n'en voulait
valoriser vos acquis en mettant votre
expérience au service d'un projet
ambitieux et novateur exactement c'est
tout à votre honneur
tata peu tendu non 1 mais je vous
rassure tout se passe très bien
vous savez ce qu'on dit en a qui ne
veulent pas l'occasion de faire une
bonne impression allez je vous rassure
la première impression est bonne
merci ce que je suis pourquoi j'essaie
de le mettre à l'aise comme ça c'est
parce qu'il est noir voulaient un petit
verdot
mais c'est ça je fais de l'empathie
parce qu'il est nous amène tout comme
l'ex que je raconte [ __ ] y'a que des
plans mais pas un seul noir pasdaran
rien que des là qu'est ce qui vous plaît
chez nous je trouve qu'une vraie culture
d'entreprise pardonner merci je recrute
que des bleus en fait on voit que c'est
une entreprise qui prend soin de ses
collaborateurs je suis raciste ça ça
donne envie de se battre à l'otc secours
cherchent un débat tant ses nerfs de la
guerre savez moi je serai là mais
attends moi je recule sur les
compétences c'est tout c'est pas
commencé moi j'ai des gens sûrs
leur couleur de peau quand même des
entreprises que c'est de nous couper les
ailes a malheureusement que qu'est-ce
que vous le dire par là des entreprises
ou l'impression qu'à couleur de peau est
encore un problème
j'étais sur des postes de représentation
un problème la couleur de peau
c'est par les entreprises à l'ancienne
pas la vôtre j'espère bien pu la
remarquer qu'il est blanc ma faute moi
j'avoue bien engagé des black et le noir
moi j'aime bien les noirs d'ailleurs n'a
pas gelé samedi enfin je m'en fous qu'il
soit noire les noirs asseman sorte à la
raison vous en êtes où alors vous avez
excusez-moi quitter votre dernier post
non non je reposte là je suis en posture
de jeudi les conquois vers l'émission je
les passe du coup à mon employeur
progrès bon d'accord donc vous managez
une petite équipe parce que je vois
comment ça se passe c'est à proprement
parler du hem à un vrai qui donne
vraiment des choses quand on me donne
son cv c'est un minimum cohérent non je
suis assez important moi j'ai besoin de
gentils mais là il ya des limites à la
discrimination positive
allez on s'arrête là quand on veut être
honnête avec vous moi ce qui me manque
la 1
je l'avais mis dans la noce c'est
l'expérience interracial internationale
justement j'ai une expérience
internationale
ah bon il est quatre ans à londres il ya
un projet c'était pas un projet phare à
écouter
[Applaudissements]
oh
maintenant on trouve une idée commune et
des petites filles vite une idée vite
sur toi sauf toi trouve un truc
oui alors [ __ ] c'est pas très sport &
spa resort vient de mourir vite le sapin
blanc un noir
oui et ça en fait je vais vous expliquer
comment vous dire oui c'est parce que
vous vous ressemblez vachement et n'ont
surtout pas surtout parce que je connais
des débats non mais si oui la
photocopieuse ça c'est la faute dans les
couples avec la photocopie non gravats
[ __ ] merde [ __ ] de là ça va pas ça
va pas ça ne va pas
q oui kim c'est ça qui me vient me voir
via là haut alors là ça va mon pote un
qui me le viet mon poto ça kim faut que
tu passes plus souvent à la maison
intel bienvenue succès c'est mon cul
c'est moi qui dit bon voilà par exemple
[Musique]
allez je vous prends vraiment
c'est pathétique gros coup de coeur gros
gros coup de coeur vraiment